[Music]
alright sleepy creepy crazy Uncle Joe
Biden well as biggest opponent right now
continues to be himself as the so-called
Democratic frontrunner still making
gaffe after gaffe there to gap blunder
after blunder he's got it worse by the
day I'm Donald Trump I'm thinking maybe
I want this guy to get the nomination
because during a recent campaign event
Oh Uncle Joe
apparently didn't even remember what
years he was the vice president he's
talking about the tragedy in parkland
Florida in 2018 the shooting which
occurred a year after he left office is
what he said about it i watch what
happened when the kids from parkland
marched up to and I met with him and
then they went off to up on the hill I
was vice president they went off the
hill to go into those neighborhoods all
those congressmen were like no I'm not
here I'm not here don't tell him I'm
around they're afraid of it they should
be exposed all right doesn't stop there
Biden is stumbling over his words and
almost every event here's just a small
little sample from Iowa let's take a
look at crazy Uncle Joe now we are we
choose unity over division we choose
science over fiction we choose truth
over facts the words that stunned the
nation I would argue I know shocked the
world international leaders spoke about
it you had people like Margaret fat
excuse me you had people like the former
chairman and leader of the party in
Germany you had a longer Merkel's we
have this notion that somehow if you're
poor you cannot do it poor kids are just
as bright in just his talons white kids
wealthy kids black kids poor kids are
just as bright as white kids and he
wasn't vice president during the
parklands shooting and he said we choose
truth over facts and Prime Minister
Thatcher has been gone a long time
and we tell you this would happen the
Biden would be spinning in a million
directions unable to stay on message his
team is running scared they don't know
what to do at this point and putting his
campaign and non-stop damage control he
did once a to it he
work in a Dunkin Donuts at 7-eleven
unless you have a slight Indian accent
then he said about Barack Obama he's
clean inarticulate this is the first
African American this is storybook man
and of course he wants to take Donald
Trump behind the school
I can can't run on the obama-biden
failed record either because not only is
that a record of failure let's see 13
million more Americans on food stamps 8
million more in poverty lowest labor
participation since the 70s worst
recovery since the 40s Donald Trump the
best employment situation since 1969 I
know I was eight years old the Mets won
the World Series can tell you the whole
lineup not only that record low
unemployment african-americans Hispanic
Americans Asian Americans women in the
workplace and youth unemployment that
didn't happen in the Biden Obama years
that happened in the Trump years after
the tax cuts after massive deregulation
after yes enticing businesses to invest
in America again and we're energy
independent for the first time in 75
years and there are energy companies
training truck drivers to drive trucks
and then starting pay 80 grand a year
this will raise the standard of living
of every American and we've got gold
under our feet and every single American
can benefit unless of course we get
Biden's version of the new Green Deal
and it's not enough by the way even left
for the new extreme Democratic Party
they want open borders they want
trillions and new entitlements they want
to get rid of the combustion engine oil
gas cows and planes which will take the
country into poverty almost
instantaneously Biden can't run on his
own Senate record either yeah remember
he was against let's see integration
that's right he wanted more segregation
he warned him quote predators on our
streets remember that particular and
even praised the former Klansmen leader
of the Democratic Party
Robert KKK bird calling him a great
friend of his at his funeral
imagine if Donald Trump did that now
it's why you can see Biden continuing to
weaponize identity politics memory will
put you all back in Chains
you know it's the try and hide from his
own disturbing people
and of course that's nothing new for the
Democratic Party here's a glimpse of the
sick and by the way this used to be
every two and four years now it's every
second of every day
this this is now full-on 2020 campaign
everything you see in here from these
candidates is all about the election